en el vídeo donde hicimos la
introducción a las series alternantes
usamos la serie que estaba dada por la
suma desde uno hasta infinito de menos
uno elevado a la n-1 verdad dividido
entre n verdad y si uno quiere nada más
dar más o menos una idea de cuál es esta
serie pues el primer término sería uno
verdad cuando n vale uno sería menos uno
al cuadrado que es uno dividido entre
uno es uno menos verdad porque va
alternando el signo uno entre dos más
uno entre tres menos uno entre cuatro y
así sucesivamente seguimos sumando
términos que van alternando el signo
verdad entonces usando el criterio para
series alternantes vimos que esta serie
converge en esta serie que converge y de
hecho podemos decir que es debido
a criterio de series alternantes de
series alternantes esta es la
justificación por la cual podemos decir
que esta serie converge verdad pero
ahora vamos vamos a repasar qué pasaría
si nosotros ponemos un valor absoluto en
estos términos y por supuesto si a lo
mejor no te acuerdas de por qué esta
serie con bergé o que es el criterio de
las series alternantes sería
recomendable que lo puedas repasar en
los vídeos anteriores muy bien entonces
vamos a ver qué pasa si nosotros ponemos
un valor absoluto a cada uno de estos
términos es decir vamos a poner el valor
absoluto de menos uno a la n 1 dividido
entre n verdad y esto pues simplemente
será la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta
infinito y por supuesto sería el valor
absoluto de lo de arriba entre el valor
absoluto de lo de abajo pero arriba
tendríamos 1 y abajo se queda como n
verdad entonces tenemos estas
desde uno hasta infinito de uno en tren
y esta es la muy famosa serie armónica
verdad que de hecho también en otro
vídeo aquí en can academy vimos que
diverge y si te interesa saber por qué
pues puedes buscarlo en nuestras listas
de vídeos verdad esto simplemente lo
podemos ver como uno más un medio más un
tercio etcétera verdad y seguimos
sumando por siempre entonces lo que
podemos garantizar es que esta serie
diverge muy bien entonces aquí tenemos
algo muy peculiar la serie original
converge sin embargo con el valor
absoluto divergen entonces cuando
tenemos una serie tal que a los términos
digamos los calculamos con valor
absoluto si esa nueva serie diverge
decimos que la serie original convergen
condicionalmente
ok cuando una serie converge
condicionalmente es porque esa serie
converge pero la serie de sus valores
absolutos divergen muy bien entonces
ahora podríamos ver
un caso contrario el caso contrario se
le va a decir que converge absolutamente
por ejemplo consideremos es la suma
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito de
menos un medio elevado a la n 1 verdad
entonces esta serie es una serie
geométrica y de hecho en los vídeos de
series geométricas como el valor
absoluto de la razón como uno de la
proporción común es menor que 1 entonces
podemos garantizar que esta serie
converge muy bien esta serie converge
ahora bien qué pasaría si nosotros
calculamos esta serie pero con los
términos tomados con valor absoluto es
decir tenemos el valor absoluto de menos
un medio
+ 1 verdad entonces esto simplemente
será la serie desde el 1 hasta infinito
de un medio elevado a la n 1 entonces
esto nuevamente vuelve a ser una serie
geométrica donde la proporción como uno
la razón común es menor que uno verdad o
su valor absoluto es menor que uno
entonces ésta también converge muy bien
entonces contrario al caso que teníamos
anteriormente aquí en la serie de los
términos con valor absoluto también
convergen entonces decimos que la
original converge absolutamente y puedes
pensar que convergen absolutamente
justamente que vienen a lo mejor de el
valor absoluto verdad entonces lo que
hemos estado haciendo en todos estos
vídeos es hablar de convergencia y
divergencia ahora no sólo eso sino que
también estamos hablando de un nuevo
tipo de convergencia es así que
podríamos pensar que hay como dos
sabores de convergencia y distintos
tipos de convergencia así que uno puede
preguntarse
si la serie converge de alguna forma sí
sí converge pero la serie de sus valores
absolutos no convergen entonces decimos
que converge condicionalmente por otro
lado si la serie se converge y también
la serie de los valores absolutos
entonces decimos que la serie convergen
absolutamente espero que este vídeo te
haya parecido interesante